dus
[Muziek
] oke
hallo en welkom iedereen
het is actief livestream nummer 47.1
op 10 augustus
en we gaan verder met onze verkenningen
in de papieren dyade inactieve dynamische
sociale cognitie en actieve gevolgtrekking
van hippalito en Venetië
en actieve gevolgtrekking en ontvoering door
pietarennen en  benny
welkom bij het act imp instituut we zijn een
participatief laboratorium en instituut dat
communiceert over leren en oefenen
toegepaste actieve inferentielinks staan op de di
dit w
rdt opgenomen in een archief lives
ream dus geef ons alsjeblieft feedb
ck zodat we ons werk allem
al kunnen verbeteren  achtergronden en perspectieven zijn
welkom
en we volgen de video-etiquette
voor livestreams
ga naar
activeinference.org voor meer informatie over
andere projecten bij het instituut en hoe u
kunt deelnemen en deelnemen aan leergroepen
vandaag in
stream 47.1
we blijven leren en  bespreek
dit paar papers die eerder
en in de vorige video zijn genoemd
en
we gaan er een paar openen
introducties en dan waarschijnlijk gewoon
binnenspringen waar
iemand een nieuwe
vraag heeft die ze willen stellen, misschien
de introducties beëindigen met blauw, zodat je
een nieuwe vector in het gesprek kunt brengen,
dus
ik ben Daniel, ik ben een onderzoeker in
Californië
en  ik kijk er naar uit
om een 0,1-lens e
en klein beetje naar het papier te brengen met e
n v
rlengde punt
, omdat er zoveel te leren was over
en paar van deze hoeken en zoveel om ov
r na te denken, um [
Muzi
k] wat i
het verschil
tussen in de badkuip zijn en dan in het
midden
van
het papierpaar
versus er bijvoorbeeld in komen om het te
contextualiseren of proberen te verlaten
om het iets ertussenin toe te passen, zelfs
daar
geef ik het door aan uh decaan
bedankt ik ben  decaan ik ben hier in Calgary um
ik weet niet of uh ik weet niet wat de
punt één betekent want we hebben nog nooit een
punt één gedaan waar we hebben geprobeerd om twee dingen te trekken
zet ze proximaal en kijk wat er gebeurt
want soms is dat
vuur en water en krijg je gewoon veel
stoom a  en soms is het uh nitro en
glycerine en het hele ding ontploft op
je, dus ik kijk er een beetje naar uit
dat dat een beetje het
riskante deel is waarvan ik denk dat het een beetje
opwindend is, ik zal het doorgeven aan stephen
hallo bedankt decaan ja  stephen hier ik ben
in toronto um
ik ben erg benieuwd
wat deze infusie van twee verschillende
benaderingen
van actieve invloed kan opleveren, dus
wat erachter zit je weet wat er
achter
een benadering van een activisme zit dat
instrumentalisme binnenbrengt
of een benadering die meer
wiskundig is  gericht
realisme brengen dus ik ben nieuwsgierig en
hopelijk zal het nuttig en praktisch zijn
ik ga het doorgeven aan
blauw
hallo ik ben blauw ik ben in new mexico
ik vond het erg leuk om te lezen dus ik heb het
gelezen  ik denk dat we de um hippolyto-
krant eerder op een andere livestream hebben gedaan
en dus heb ik die eerder gelezen, maar ik vond het
erg leuk om deze
ontvoering te lezen en was actief in de franse krant ik
heb geen sterke filosofische achtergrond, dus
ik kom eigenlijk bij  dit vind ik leuk  met een wat is
dit, wat is dat, zoals ik
100 miljoen keer op wikipedia moet zoeken
om meer informatie te krijgen
over een filosofisch aspect en dus
een van de belangrijkste dingen, zoals waar ik
het moeilijk had, zoals insluiten
op  deze ontvoeringspapieren actieve gevolgtrekking
en ontvoering
is eh
waarom
doe je eerst in dekens
zoals ze presenteerden de auteurs
presenteerden het alsof de eerste en
dekens zoals een realistisch
perspectief nodig hebben, dus dat is waar en zo ja,
waarom is
dat goed,
bedankt iedereen
dus  twee
draden blauw in wat ik
hoorde en ik denk dat twee gebieden voor ons
om op de dia te komen en tegelijkertijd te
zien,
dus één was als verschillende benaderingen
die zowel door een persoon kunnen worden gevolgd,
zoals verschillende achtergronden in
verschillende velden of disciplines
en dan een beetje verder gaan dan
het leertraject van één persoon
en bedenken wat de
conceptuele benaderingen zijn die we kunnen gebruiken
om in dit geval actieve gevolgtrekking te maken,
maar dit kan
studie zijni  Het gebruik van actieve inferentie en het toepassen van
actieve inferentie op beide manieren
kan een rol spelen
en dan de vraag van de eerste en
dekens
zoiets als welke aspecten van wat
een situationeel realist
of een
instrumentalist in staat stelt
waarom mensen de standpunten
innemen die ze innemen
[Muziek]
in een bepaalde situatie,
soms zelfs als
ze in verschillende contexten voor
hetzelfde systeem worden gemengd, kunnen ze het een of het
ander of iets dergelijks gebruiken,
en dit brengt actie terug in de
vergelijking. Ik heb het gevoel dat actie heel
belangrijk is omdat
het idee van instrumentalisme in een  manier
is er een gebruik van
bepaalde instrumenten um en dat is
de beste manier
om te denken aan wat er gebeurt met de
dekens eigenlijk vind ik het echt
cool dat je de dekens naar voren bracht
want uh
die vraag van
uh komt weet je op een actieve manier dat het is
zoals de verleiding is om
alles realistisch te maken en dan is het
goed, we hebben een deken, dus het is een beetje
zoals
misschien kunnen we  we moeten ervoor zorgen dat we de
algemene vraag op een instrumentele manier
houden om al die valstrikken te vermijden en aan de
andere kant is het alsof
aan de wiskundige kant het is alsof
deze
potentieel fundamentele
dynamiek
goed is, aangezien ze op de een of andere manier worden gehandeld,
ze moeten wat hebben  relatie tot de werkelijkheid
op de een of andere
manier dus het is bijna de spiegel
het is niet de spiegel maar het is iets
dat op een interessante manier aan de andere kant zit
ik weet niet wat
decaan denkt vanaf dat punt maar um
[muziek]
i ik ik
ging naar  vermeld dat
ik denk dat als we twee papers nemen en
eigenlijk
een beetje doen wat er gebeurt als ze
verstrikt raken, we kijken naar wat
er gebeurt als iets actief wordt
afgeleid als een proces in tegenstelling tot
actieve gevolgtrekking als een onderwerp of
onderwerp
en dus als we dat doen, vragen we in wezen
wat de grote vragen op een van de
volgende dia's hier zijn,
dus is actieve gevolgtrekking zowel als proces
als actief afleiden en van proces
valt iets uit  dat en
we vroegen het in het gebruik van de
metafoor van zowel een grijper zijn
als iets als verwerking en een
proces dat wordt gegrepen en dus um
ja, ik denk dat als we
als we er echt naar kijken als
wat er aan de hand is, niet alleen  van het
doende gevoel maar van het
observerende gevoel of participatief gevoel
um
ik denk dat het ons geen andere keuze laat dan
te
zeggen dat er wat
heen en weer moet gaan tussen beide, maar
dat is slechts mijn mening
,
dus laat me dit citaat lezen van
het papier um gaat specifiek terug
naar de deken degene die
mijn mijn mijn vraag-bel deed afgaan dat is als
onbeantwoord
eh het zegt
um oke volgens recente
interpretaties van de fep de dynamische
interactie van levende systemen en de
externe wereld onder actieve gevolgtrekking
kan  semantisch worden geïnterpreteerd dit is
een citaat uit 2020 door aan te nemen
dat zintuiglijke toestanden betekenisvolle
representaties zijn van de werkelijkheid.
Dit is vooral het geval als we aannemen
dat de ontwikkeling  nt van Markov-dekens
door fristen, in
tegenstelling tot hun oorspronkelijke karakterisering
en werken van Judea Pearl op
probabilistische causale netwerken, laten een
realistische interpretatie toe van de
relatie tussen het organisme en
de omgeving,
zo staat er, terwijl de rol van de
concepten van Markov-dekens en pareldekens
in veel behandelingen  van het principe van vrije
energie is een
instrumentalistische, terwijl in pierce's nog sterkere
bewoordingen toegeven aan een nominalistische
interpretatie van hun betekenis eerst in
dekens zijn realistisch, niet alleen in de
niet-instrumentalistische zin, maar ook in
de zin van niet-nominalistische
entiteiten de modale termen  van verwijzingen
naar reële mogelijkheden, zoals wat
denkbaar is of wordt voortgebracht door verbeeldingskracht
of anticiperend verband houdt met de
toekomstige stand van zaken, worden gebruikt
om de belangrijkste aspecten van de theorie te begrijpen
en dus in mijn herinnering de eerste
in deken zoals ik deed'  t heb dat
per se noodzakelijkerwijs gekoppeld aan realisme,
dus
daniel zoals misschien ken do yo  je hebt nog
meer verduidelijking, zoals dat als een
realist een eerste keer deken een
realistische interpretatie is van de
pareldeken of of ben ik gewoon vergeten dat
toen ik dat deel las
ik niet wist wat nominalisme was,
dus volgens de samenvatting
het uitzicht  dat universalia en abstracte
objecten niet echt bestaan, behalve
dat het alleen maar
namen of labels zijn, de
ene versie ontkent het bestaan van unive
salia de an
ere de abstracte dus het is een anti-
eneralistische positie dus laten we eens kijken waar
at werd gebruikt met de eerste en deken
want
it is de  um
[Muziek]
kern
van de discussie als een van de
grenzen van contact
anders dan gewoon goed zeggen een activisme
en dynamische systeemtheorie werken
zo grof of dit brede gebied wiskunde
en scheikunde werken op deze manier samen
dit begint in het echte
contact te komen  punten van
turf die
semantisch over mensen worden bevochten, hebben verschillende
perspectieven op
hoe
basisgrafieken in verschillende contexten moeten worden geïnterpreteerd,
en dus t  de Markov-deken
het is alsof het nog steeds te
grofkorrelig is
om die hele grasmat
door een of ander gezichtspunt te laten beheersen,
dus
laten we dan eens kijken
hoe het ontvoeringspapier
en al het andere dat je
ziet,
waar zou het meer gerechtvaardigd zijn, alleen in
jouw zin
um
[Muziek]
wat en dan zullen we dit uitpakken omdat
ik denk dat dit zojuist is gekopieerd
om vandaag te bespreken,
omdat het duidelijk een duidelijk gebied is waar
beide kranten het hebben over hun mening
over de markup-deken, wat het
misschien duidelijker maakt
om te zien hoe meerdere  opvattingen over
dekens en
grafieken spelen een rol,
maar laten we hun beide perspectieven eens uitpakken,
gezien de nominalistische um-
interpretatie en terwijl je dat
uitpakt alsof het iets is dat ik
niet hoefde op te zoeken omdat het een
zeer prominent thema is in het
boeddhisme, zoals  dat eh je weet dat
het is alsof de afwezigheid van enige vorm van
inherent bestaan alsof dat besta
n nominaal is en dus is h
t interessant dat in dit ontvoerings
ocument dat ze dit
it
it nemen  eh,
je kent de constructie door middel van
nominalisme, maar ook zoals meer dan
eens in dat document
wijzen ze naar een objectieve realiteit uh wat
is alsof als dingen worden
geïnterpreteerd als alle dingen nominaal worden
geïnterpreteerd,
wat is deze objectieve realiteit
dan anders dan zoals  linguïstiek of semantiek of
misschien semiotiek
um ja, dus
zelfs
dat is een heel goed punt eh omdat het
ook teruggaat naar je zei over eh
toen we het daar hadden over de
relatie die bijna de realiteit was ik
voelde dat ze een soort van zeiden of
er een relatie is
die relationele
dynamiek of ze hebben het woord dynamiek niet gebruikt,
daarom
hebben
sommige
kunnen echt worden genoemd,
wat volgens mij in sommige opzichten een eerlijke bewering is,
hoewel
je weet dat
er een overmatige uitbreiding kan zijn omdat
er een vraag is over hoeveel je gaat
omhoog naar transcendentaal
en hoeveel je afdaalt
in
het soort meer morfologie en
de hele morfogenese en er is
eigenlijk een echt goo  d er is een
hector lazar hij is eigenlijk het doet
veel met theater van de onderdrukten
en werkte met
je weet dat mensen zijn gemarteld en
dat soort dingen en hij praat over
eh het medicijn zit in de wonden het
medicijn zit in de wonden als mensen
leer je
trauma kennen enz. en een van de dingen die
interessant zijn, is dat
we misschien in een cultuur zitten, er zijn tijden
dat we proberen dingen uit te leggen of
transcendentaal werk
te doen om een situatie te overstijgen of on
te vermijden en we kunnen eigenlijk een situa
ie vermijden  maar soms als je
de wond ingaat, is
wat je zou kunnen vinden letterlijk een
bloederige puinhoop
dus
dat is misschien niet echt in de normale zin
weet je
laten we daar nog een klein beetje aan toevoegen ik
denk dat het interessant is dat de meeste
afbeeldingen van markov-dekens laten zien
de markov-
deken tussen
twee
verschillende
um-
sets van eigenschappen en die wordt
altijd horizontaal weergegeven
en ik denk dat wat hier interessant is, is
dat als je
precies als je vindt  jezelf
in een debatsituatie
van twee top-down perspectieven, een die
zegt
dat het van bovenaf en actief
moet zijn of dat het van bovenaf moet zijn een of
andere
reeks van
een reeks of een reeks verschillende logica's
toegepast, afhankelijk van je bekendheid
met  wat het is dat je waarneemt
dat kan leiden tot die hele kwestie van
goed
hiërarchie en wat dan de ander inhoudt,
dus voor mij
is het mooi, het is vrij
gemakkelijk te begrijpen waarom
mensen die
de exclusieve positie van
instrumentalisme innemen als
iets als logica
of  de andere hiërarchische
relatie van
de logica is het echte ding
en dan
de acties die moeten worden gevolgd of dat is het
ding dat wordt meegebracht
.  ga
kijken naar die laterale
minder
die het andere
bovenaanzicht omhult, omdat
beide weergaven in beide
artikelen
de vooringenomenheid of
de positie th  de auteurs nemen is er
een van boven naar beneden
wat regels
onder deze reeks voorwaarden of
omstandigheden
die twee dingen naast elkaar plaatsen
, een aantal van de vragen rond relativiteit wegnemen
en nu het idee introduceren van een
relatie en geen relatie in termen
van macht over
maar relatie in termen van
wat aanwezig moet zijn zodat
iemand in staat is om daadwerkelijk
minder voorspellingsfouten te maken,
dus
de markup-deken
kan volgens
mij worden omgedraaid, ik bedoel op dit moment wordt het meeste
gezien als een soort
verticale partitie  tussen
laterale
elementen, ik bedoel, het kan worden omgedraaid en
we hebben vaak in veel kranten gesproken
over wat de hiërarchische structuur is,
wat is de bottom-up, wat is de top-down,
maar ik denk dat beide papers
weliswaar zeggen dat
we een top-down weergave van  dit
en daarom beperken ze
zich tot
meer
nadruk op het relativiteitsaspect van
wat zich daarin afspeelt op een actief
afleidende manier dan dat ze kijken  g zie
het als een relatie tussen het voelen
en het
acteren oke wow een heleboel dingen
laten we door de ontvoering gaan
Markov algemene discussie
het eerste deel is de verklaring van de
context mogelijk voor een filosofische
achtergrond, maar het is belangrijk dat
ze dit
erbij plaatsen  de lijnen van
autopoëse en biologie, dus dit zijn
systemen die zichzelf in stand houden
op een diffuse, meerschalige manier van zichzelf
misschien,
maar ze zijn
zelfcreërend.  opnieuw nadenken over systemen
die
een niet-evenwichtige stabiele
toestand hebben behouden met hun omgeving
en zo niet de omgeving als iemand
het realisme of
iets van de omgeving ontkent,
dan
kan dat worden verwoord en zelfs herkend, maar
het wordt ook niet vastgesteld door persistente
systemen  van het uitzicht van binnenuit
of zoals als men gewoon
stopt met ademen of iets dergelijks
of het uitzicht van buitenaf want
weer systemen met p  aanhoudende
metingen
moeten het op zijn
minst goed genoeg doen om te blijven bestaan
en van de regelmatigheden van de omgev
ng, dus d
t lijkt een beetje op het aarden in een e
olutionair en ontwi
kelingskader, maar het verbinden met het niet-
venwichtsbehoud dat d
ze realisme-discus
sie in  een relatie met de
omgeving
niet zoals in a priori
dan is er een definitie van markov
deken
de algemene toestand voorwaardelijke
onafhankelijkheid tussen knooppunten in een
basisgrafiek wat niet betekent dat invloed
niet reist of dat die
toestanden niet semantisch over elkaar gaan  andere
maar het betekent dat ze voorwaardelijk
onafhankelijk zijn op een statistische manier
externe toestanden
in sabosku niet zeker van deze auteur, maar de
endosomische weergave
zou zijn als een
potentiële betekenis aan de binnenkant, zoals
fotonen op het netvlies echt licht zijn,
het is echt zo dat dat de
echt ding
binnen dat facet van biologische functie
en interne toestanden beschreven vanuit
exosemiotic  perspectief dus misschien zoals
de interpretatieve weergave dus bekijk van
binnenuit de ware invloed van een
kenmerk
en het soort studie ervan uitzicht vanaf
de buitenkant waar iedereen het erover eens is
dat je semiosis hebt zoals met een stopbord
en het betekent stop
in de situatie met verschillende  entiteiten,
dit spreekt rechtstreeks tot actieve gevolgtrekking,
aangezien de regulering van de entropie
van interne toestanden, dus al deze
functies die we beschrijven
als begrensd of beperkt of geminimaliseerd
, te maken hebben met
de verrassingscontrole van die interface
op uitgaande en vervolgens begrensde
verrassing  op perceptie die
ook erg sterk verouderd is, zoals de
perceptuele controletheorie en verschillende
motortheorieën waar we het over hebben gehad,
maar zoals de reflexboog
die de manier uitdaagt waarop mensen
besluitvorming modelleren,
bijvoorbeeld,
en
in veel behandelingen zijn ze het
erover eens dat mensen  neem een
mentalist gebruik of st
ndpunt chris
elijke dekens zijn realistisch, niet alleen in de
niet-instrumentalisten se  nse
opent een hele discussie met non en
anti,
maar ook in de zin van
niet-nominalistische entiteiten
en dan zou het in dit laatste citaat
geweldig zijn om meer van de auteurs te horen
over wat de modale
taakomschrijving is, behalve het deel  wat
hier opvalt, zijn de echte mogelijkheden,
want voor deze systemen
met deze kenmerken die op deze manier bezig
zijn,
kan hun cognitie als echt worden beschouwd
in de mate dat het al deze
kenmerken heeft en in de loop van de tijd aan de omgeving is gebonden
enzovoort
hoop dat
is één mening  omdat veel
paragrafen in de ontvoeringspaper en inactieve paper
als je je echt bezighoudt met hun
gestructureerde argumenten er zoveel leuks is om
tussendoor te lezen
en
de manier te respecteren waarop ze het argument hebben uiteengezet,
terwijl ze
hopelijk nu allemaal
interessante manieren zien om  verbind het dus
Stephen en dan iemand anders
ja dit is een beetje een
soort feedback naar jou Daniel, dus voor het
geval je hier een mening over hebt, maar
omdat
je weet dat het daar is'  Er is hier het
biologische aspect
dat je aansnijdt en daar ben ik het mee eens
en
je weet dat Tristan in het werk aan de
hersenen heeft gesproken over de
overgang van bijvoorbeeld een causale correlatie naar
een functionele correlatie
en er kunnen veel manieren zijn om
ergens als het functioneel is,
dus dan is er
natuurlijk een bepaald element van
wat echt is in termen van wat we
wetenschappelijk hebben omdat het wetenschappelijk
realisme is als wetenschapper wat echt is
wat wetenschappelijk is afgeleid,
dus als het deductief is, is het een
perspectief dat wordt  zo genomen binnen
het perspectief dat wordt genomen op
bepaalde
staten niet-evenwicht stabiele toestanden
waar is
dat
regime van aandacht het wetenschappelijke
regime van aandacht
puur een instrument om te overwegen of
is het
voor de dingen die het analyseert die
echt kunnen zijn,
dus er zou kunnen zijn  een soort
uitstapclausule,
maar er kan nog steeds een
fenomeen zijn in
plaats van
perspectieven en logica
die eronder zitten  die
veel dynamiek hebben om tot hetzelfde
resultaat te komen, dus wat is je mening over die
daniel
mijn gedachten ik wil horen wat blue en
dean erover zouden zeggen oke kom op
oh ja steve eerst
ga je gang ga je gang blauw
nu ga ervoor dean ik  wil horen wat
je te zeggen hebt oke
dus hier is een interessant ding
over beide papers en misschien zullen de
auteurs van de papers hier
hard op terugdringen maar geweldig dat is wat ik
gewend ben dat
beide papers hier een wetenschappelijk
perspectief op nemen
heel erg is mijn typische perspectief
dat in mijn boeken gemakkelijk
als een idioom is
als ik het zie ik zal het geloven ze willen
het juiste bewijs ze willen het ze
willen dat soort inductief deductief
stuk dat soort van vooraan en in het midden zit
ze willen  bewijs
dat is geweldig, ik snap dat, maar wat
ik echt fascinerend vind,
is dat ze
die epistemische
prioriteit vasthouden waar ze ook veel over praten.
Ik zal dat omdraaien en ze zeggen dat ik het zal
geloven
als ik  het zien
dus er is veel vertrouwen in het
is nog niet uitgekomen, maar als ik
blijf bestaan
sociale omgeving of al
agent raad
ens wat ik moet geloven dat al die t
jd dat blijft uitro
len, ik ga
door voor
at dan ook  doeleinden doelen of
richtlijnen die ik neem
om
er doorheen te werken
het niet te zien
totdat ik daadwerkelijk
op dat moment aankom waarop iets zich
materialiseert en ik kan zeggen oh
nu heb ik het bewijs dus er is een
beide kranten hebben een echte
ze spelen ze spelen met zichzelf ze
dans met zichzelf in de zin dat
het beide artikelen zijn vanuit een expliciet
standpunt die zeggen dat we kijken naar
het wetenschappelijk en wiskundig
en toch om dit vast te kunnen
houden
deze gedachte of het idee dat de fpp
u bent  weet ik ben ik ben ik ben
ik ben wat men ook wel stationaire toestand noemt ik ben
zojuist de uitdrukking verloren niet-evenwicht
bedankt niet-evenwicht staat staat ik
moet wel ergens in geloven
voor welk materialisatiedoel dan ook  O  r
resultaat waar ik naar toe ga als dat
homeostase of allostase is of ik wil over
vijf minuten sandwichen ik moet
geloven in dat ding of mijn keuzevrijheid of mijn
vermogen om te bereiken of te bereiken
voordat ik
het ding
echt
kan hebben  alleen al vanuit die opvatting
vind ik het echt interessant dat
er een zekere mate van naïviteit
in beide kranten zit, er is een soort van a we
moeten onze hoed kantelen voor deze beginnende opvatting
dat elke keer dat we ons
iets realiseren
er een klein beetje geloof moet zijn  of
een beetje geloof
in wat er aan de hand is, die priors
bestaan echt en ik ga ze gebruiken omdat
ik wil uitvoeren wat mijn prior
teiten ook zijn en he
maakt niet uit of he
de top downiness is van ontvo
ring en logica of de top  neer
van een activisme
ze houden allebei hun hoed op de bodem uppiness
ik moet een soort van een ik moet er een soort van
vertrouwen in hebben
dat zelfs als het er nu niet is, het op een gegeven
moment zal doorgaan zoals ik
het wil of wat dan ook  ik wil het
opleggen ik heb dat vermogen om
het af te wachten en dat ding te laten gebeuren
dus
ja dat is wat ik zou toevoegen aan wat
Stephen zei
oke
ja dus
ik zal een paar dingen zeggen um
ik keek gewoon naar  nu het verschil
tussen een
eerste en zoals wat is de eerste in
deken en ik kwam een artikel tegen dat we zu
len moeten bespreken uh het heet
etenschappelijk realisme over eerst in deken
zonder letterlijkheid en het is door kimbe
stein en kirk kirchoff um zo
op een dag  we zullen moeten hebben
dat het nu een pre-print is op een
filosofisch archief, dus
blijkbaar kan het hebben van een echte
grens zo letterlijk zijn alsof
er een letterlijke interpretatie of
een realistische interpretatie is en en dus net
zoals ik nog steeds probeer  om te beperken,
zoals wat is deze realistische interpretatie
van een frisse deken eh
en
ja,
dus
het is ook in een heel reële zin zoals wat
is de echte grens van een levend wezen
eh zoals
ik niet ik kan mijn echte grens niet vinden
zoals waar  stop ik en
begint er iets anders eh er zijn honderden en
zo'n biljoenen ik weet niet eens meer
niet-menselijke cellen in mijn lichaam dan
er menselijke cellen zijn, dus ik moet hier altijd op
terugkomen, dus wat zou ik zijn
zonder  al die niet-menselijke dingen
zijn die niet-menselijke dingen die ik ook leuk vind,
maar zoals je weet ben ik constant bezig
met het
innemen van nieuwe en het uitscheiden van
oude en zo en ze komen
in mijn huid en verlaten mijn huid zo
waar is mijn
grens zoals moet ik deze
grens hebben om actieve gevolgtrekking te maken
en zoals de markov-
dekeninterpretatie om toe te passen ik weet niet
dat dat
noodzakelijkerwijs waar is,
dus
alsof ik er gewoon vanaf kan ik hou van
dit papier en ik  liefde zoals de semiotische
interpretatie in zoals de abductieve
betekenis zoals maar maakt het zelfs echt
uit zoals
zoals de echtste interpretatie zoals voor
iemand die niet in like gelooft een
gedeelde objectieve realiteit zal
nooit werken
of zoals kan je de grens vinden  zoals
wat is deze lijn tussen zelf en ander
of zoals tussen
zoals zoals zoals ik kan de grens niet vinden zo
zoals voor mij het is allemaal een
modelleringsperspectief dat de
impact van
deze ontvoering niet vermindert als actief gevolgtrekkingspapier
voor mij helemaal zoals  alsof ik echt dacht dat
het een geweldig papier was en veel
echt coole dingen te zeggen heeft over
cognitie en perceptie dus
zoals waarom hangen we hier op nog steeds ik
weet het niet
oke jullie gaan ervoor en dan zal ik
voeg wat aantekeningen toe
kan ik er nog een toevoegen
ik bedoel ik denk dat
ik het helemaal eens ben met decaan over
dit bottom-up
fenomeen je weet dat dat
er op de achtergrond zal zijn
misschien zal het altijd onkenbaar zijn
afgezien van sommige van  deze simulaties
geven ons inzichten, maar
ik denk ook dat wat blauw zegt, er
is voor mij
deze hele grensvraag
waar het probleem zit met de
systeemdiscussie
in termen van dat het een beetje
genaturaliseerd is
en ik denk dat het komt omdat je eindigt
met  h omdat systemen op die manier zijn gedefinieerd,
wat binnen is wat buiten is
en voor mij de grote openbaring
en ik denk dat voor veel mensen in
de biologische wetenschappen
het niet zo ongebruikelijk is om op deze manier
te denken, maar om na te denken over op agent gebaseerde modellering
om na te denken over waar  de agent waar is
de instantie de teleologie
en
die
instantie zit niet per se op een
grens zoals systemen de neiging hebben
ik bedoel iemand kan beweren dat het niet
hoeft en ik weet zeker dat het niet zo is, maar het
eindigt  het komt bijna altijd
precies daar terecht in termen van discours,
dus u weet dat we willen
dat dat discours duidelijk is.
weet waar we het over hebben en waarom,
maar
dat is waar er misschien een uitdaging is
dit
agentbureau teleologie morfologische
um dynamiek is
iets anders dan dat en ik zal dat
doorgeven aan Daniel en misschien zullen zijn mieren
c  kom ergens binnen ik weet het niet zeker
decaan eerst dan ga ik ervoor ik zal
heel snel zijn hier dus in sommige van de
diagrammen weet ik
daniel je bent hier heel goed in
enkele van de diagrammen de markov deken
is letterlijk een ovaal met het woord
discrepantie
erin
en dus alles wat ik zou doen om toe
te voegen aan wat blauw zei, is
dat
als je een harde fysieke grens
wilt en je wilt ontdekken wat dat is
, ik denk dat je op zoek bent  nogmaals
wat
waar is dit waar is eindigt het
ene ding en begint het andere als een
relativiteitsvraag wat ik suggereer
is
als je naar bottom-up
en top-down kijkt als een relatie, niet als een
wat is wat is  krachtiger of heeft
meer invloed op de ander je
ziet dat als een relatie dan
is het die relatie
als een discrepantiezone
het is niet per se iets dat
een fysiek
begin en einde heeft
het is een soort van vloeibaar
en het
en dit is  om niet te zeggen dat we niet
naar de relativit moeten kijken  y stuk is om te
zeggen laten we een oog op het relativiteitsstuk hebben
en het andere oog op het
relatiestuk de discrepantie
ertussen niet het
leent zich niet voor harde
stops
het is discrepantie als dat alles is
dat is precies
wat  het betekent dat
we nergens zeker
van zijn, behalve dat ze
anders zijn,
we weten niet
waar de scheidingsgrens is, maar
dat is een beetje waar dit geheel, laten
we deze twee papieren bij elkaar brengen,
vandaan kwam, want
als we actief zijn  concluderen
dat we die discrepantie kunnen omzeilen,
het hoeft niet altijd een partitie te zijn
dat is wat de
dat is wat de prijs hier
potentieel is als we
twee
dingen tegelijkertijd of
gelijktijdig kunnen
houden oke wow
nou veel daar eerst goed  met de
discrepanties leerboek figuur twee drie
discrepantie
geen deken of discrepantie als deken
of deken enz.
en
dat kan een continue of discrete
waarde zijn, maar in niet-geïdealiseerde
zoals niet-enkelvoudig pad van lea  st actie-
instellingen
oftewel echte instellingen er is altijd een
waarde die niet nul is,
dus dat is een manier om de deur
altijd een beetje open te laten
op een manier dat
gewoon twee voeten op
nul of een
of een snelle schakelstrategie van
nullen en enen niet echt is  leg
dat
op dezelfde manier vast
, blauwe grote vraag, zoals
we in het begin een beetje vroegen
waarom wat iemand ertoe brengt om
zoiets
als een deken in een realistisch of een
instrumentalistisch licht te beschouwen
en wees op factoren zoals de
persistentie van het organisme en  de
realiteit van zoals de actie in stroom met
zijn omgeving, dus
iemand dwingt om goed te zeggen als de
omgeving echt is, dan zijn de entiteit en de acties
en de semiosis van hun acties
echt als stopborden echt zijn en stoppen
bij een stopbord is  echt en ze maken allemaal
deel uit van een niet-evenwichtige stabiele toestand
wat wil je nog meer
realisme weten dan dat
alsof er een territorium is
en dan zijn dit de kaarten van het
territorium dus  iemand gaat
helemaal in territorium
scepticisme
of hoe zullen ze dan hun standpunt herformuleren
um
dan
op de slechts een paar andere willekeurige stukken
dit was in livestream drie
toen we lazen over communicatie
in actieve gevolgtrekking
en dat is wat veel is  in de
sociale inactiviteit die we
dit ontvoerende
licht naar de sociale en actieve setting brengen,
dat is echt zoals
uiteengezet in de hippolyta en van
's paper dat dat ingaat op veel van de
wetenschappelijke en filosofische aspecten van
sociale
um, dus hier zijn
ze'  opnieuw
lenen van het raamwerk van
de vier vragen van Tim Bergen
en
meerdere
analyseschalen bieden
die allemaal lijken op de vier y's
en deze vier y's zijn een soort van
twee bij twee kwadrant
en dus maakt dat in de
biologie
parallelle onderzoeksagenda's
en integratie mogelijk,
omdat zoals  het feit dat hersengebieden
hier aan
de kant van het mechanisme met elkaar verbonden zijn,
maakt deel uit van het plaatje, maar het is een ja
en met het patroon van
dna-divergentietijden zoals je
je situaties kunt voorstellen waarin ze al dan niet
gecorreleerd zijn en ze kunnen wel of niet worden
veroorzaakt en het kan een
manier van oorzakelijk verband zijn of een verstorende factor
of een ander aantal dingen
en dan hebben geen van beide een directe
gesloten deur  zoals hoe het vogelgezang
klinkt, dus zonder zelfs maar in te gaan op
hoe het vogelgezang is geïnterpreteerd,
want er is nog
steeds ruimte binnen die
interpretatieve of semiotische wetenschappelijke
benadering
die
hopelijk is zoals we kunnen
onderzoeken door
het onderzoek en de toepassing
op een andere manier te bekijken dan  het is
in het verleden opgedeeld in bepaalde specifieke analyses
decaan
dus hier zal ik iets naar buiten gooien
wetende dat ik er niet echt
meer over heb nagedacht dan terwijl ik
naar je luisterde,
dus als het helemaal verkeerd
is, kan iemand het  corrigeer me heel
snel ik denk dat het echt interessant is
dat
beide artikelen
bieden wat ik zou beschouwen als een
stabiel of een stabiliserend effect  fect op
wat
we zouden kunnen omschrijven als
iets dat lijkt op strategie
voor het potentieel voor strategie
waar ik altijd aan denk is de
strategie niet gedrag gedrag dat
meestal het label tactiek krijgt,
maar strategie omvat wel de
anticipatie en de logica die wordt
toegepast en ik denk  dat is waar
we niet in conflict zijn als we zeggen dat
er een triadisch is en dat er een
co-constructie is van de sociale scène,
omdat ik denk dat beide
dingen de stille stabiliteit of het
platform bieden om vervolgens
die voorspellingsfouten te strategiseren en te minimaliseren,
zodat
we opnieuw kunnen  toch kunnen we nog steeds voortbouwen
op strategie en doen
en we kunnen nog steeds voortbouwen op strategie
en
constante slechte consequente beslissingen elimineren,
dus
nogmaals, dat is de relatie in
tegenstelling tot
welke van deze twee benaderingen deze
twee top-down benaderingen
is het ding dat  heeft de meeste
invloed, omdat op een gegeven moment het
een of het ander of beide, zolang je
er niet in verstrikt
raakt, eigenlijk de  de meeste zou volgens
mij de meest optie zijn die niet
is geselecteerd, omdat ze in het
inductiedocument praten over
de verschillende
soorten ontvoering,
maar ze benadrukken ook sterk
dat uiteindelijk beide soorten het
genereren en
selecteren in wezen
jij zijn, je kunt  je kunt het een niet hebben zonder
het ander,
dus
dat is interessant
om hier ook op te nemen
of je moet overwegen ik zeg niet dat
je het moet opnemen,
maar als je het deed, hoe zou dat
eruit zien  direct reageren een paar stukjes
daar dan steven dan wie dan ook dus
zeer interessant verband met
multi-schaal
voorspellingsfout of vrije energie
minimalisatie onzekerheid reductie
verrassende begrenzing
in multi-schaal systemen
en dan in deze sociaal inactieve setting
die
hippolyta en van ness naar de voorgrond brachten
dat is
onze grijper en gegrepen
op een manier dat een klein
experiment
op een vast spiegelactief inferentiesysteem
of systeem beschreven door een van de
kloosters  ionele mechanica
klassieke fysica mechanica statistische
thermodynamica kwantum
soort van begint gewoon een
opmaat voor
aanstaande discussies met dalton,
maar ik denk dat we een aspect naar voren zullen halen
, namelijk dat de bayesiaanse
mechanica
die discussie verbreedt tot de
cognitieve dynamiek
van actieve deeltjes
en zo  op die manier wordt een bal die
valt als een speciaal geval van
vallende actieve deeltjes
die verschillende paden kunnen nemen op basis van
hun belichaamde eigenschappen,
zelfs als ze alleen worden beschreven alsof het
honkbal niet de paraboolvergelijking volgt
, maar dat is hoe de echte
omgeving en het actieve deeltje op elkaar inwerken
dat wil zeggen semiotisch,
daarom noemen ze beide
kranten ontvoering in de sociale
context
en toen noemde je deze twee
top-down perspectieven
en hoe als we de divergentie hebben
tussen een probleem met meerdere drie lichamen
, we meerdere ideeën hebben,
minimaal twee
hopelijk  meer
en dan zijn er vreemde aantrekkers
,
er is live str  eam 32 er is
livestream 26 alles gebeurt in die
ruimte van boven naar beneden,
want er zullen altijd
meerdere zijn van onder naar boven,
dus de enige fout
die niet
alleen de juiste grove korreling zou zijn,
is een enkelvoudig
oog van mordorlaser
en  dat leidt in
wezen tot onverwachte onverwachte dingen
met de realiteit van onderop
en als er dan divergenties zijn en
continue toestandsruimten en paden
ertussen van boven naar beneden,
dan is er een bidirectionele
relatie met boven naar beneden en
onder naar boven of binnen naar buiten en de
buiten naar binnen omdat je er zelfs tussen zou kunnen bewegen
zonder het gevoel te hebben dat
we een systeem overtreden
om soms links naar rechts te gebruiken voor
tijd en dan zouden we rechts naar links kunnen gebruiken
voor tijd en dat soort
cognitieve bewegingen dus als toegankelijk te zien
in een sociale  instellen
en vervolgens afsnijden die koers ten slotte aan
u zei dat de tweetaktmotor van
ontvoering met genereren en selecteren
omdat de laser geen generator is
en dat is nu de analogie van
aandacht
in een talk-down-systeem zoals we
gemodelleerde en mentale actie
meerdere keren hebben gezien stephen
ja bedankt daniel um
zou je in staat zijn om terug te gaan naar die
vier aan vier die je daar had um
met de ultieme ja  en
ik denk dat dit heel belangrijk is,
want
er is ook een impliciete
aanname van verlichting die altijd op
de achtergrond zat,
waar omhoog goed is
en
ik denk dat het daar echt interessant is
dat en ik denk dat je helemaal gelijk hebt
we praten erover praat over het ultieme
wat  ik denk dat het heel nieuwsgierig is en het
gaat over jou weet dat we het hebben over deze
interacties dus dit soort interactie
dit is de ultieme reeks interacties
het roodborstje en
dat is wat de waarheid wordt gezien als wat is
de rationele waarheid
als we omhoog gaan en we krijgen  verlicht,
zodat we kunnen projecteren
op wat er is en het idee dat
wat er komt
interacties zijn, dat is de algemene manier waarop het wordt
gedacht en er was een magische doos
ca  lled opkomst om
het feit te omzeilen dat we het echt niet wisten,
maar ik zou dat willen uitdagen
niet om niet te zeggen dat dat niet waar is in
termen van hoe het wordt waargenomen, maar
er is een andere manier waarop bottom-up kan
worden onderzocht en dat is  een andere manier waarop de
waarheid kan worden onderzocht, er is een
rationele waarheid
en er is
waarvan ik dacht dat het ultieme vrij was
intieme waarheid
is anders dan rationele waarheid
en intieme waarheid gaat niet over
interacties, het gaat over weten
oké,
het gaat over een dieper soort weten,
dus als ik naar beneden ga, is het niet
wat er in een bottom-up naar boven komt,
het is wat ik
goed doe mijn enige manier om deel te nemen  het is om erin af te
dalen is dat logisch
en dat erin afdalen
ook waardevol is
het is niet primitiever
dan verlichting
en ik denk dat
eh
dat gaat naar een soort van  een zeer
fundamentele veronderstelling waarvan we niet
eens merken dat het er is over de wetenschap
dat alles probeert te worden
verlicht, maar dat
is slechts gedeeltelijk waar en ik denk dat de
biologie dat min of meer weet, maar er misschien
toch niet mee kan praten dat is
mijn kleine stukje daar
om te
proberen die ene laag dichter bij elkaar te brengen,
denk ik dat sommige academische tradities maar geenszins
genormeerde zijn, maar bedankt voor iedereen voor het
delen ervan,
het doet me denken aan de richting die is ingeslagen
in de
uh een van de biografieën die ik in de titel zal plakken
hier is dit de biografie van evelyn fox keller
van barbara mcclintock
en de titel is een gevoel voor het
organisme
en uh
dat
neemt een door de
geschiedenis en filosofie van de wetenschap
geïnformeerde kijk op zoals wat is het gevoel
voor het organisme
hoe heb je een gevoel voor de
chromosomen zoals  deze overtuiging dat
er springgenen waren
van
bepaalde psychologische um-observaties
en
hoe werkt dat dan echt als
iemand zich in een
professionele context bevindt  en zoals verwachtingen
rond verschillende mensen die er
anders uitzien enzovoort,
dus dat heeft een holistische kijk en ik
denk dat er in deze elke of
vele gevallen
dat soort verhaal te vertellen is
en dus
dat is een brug van verbinding
blauw
vanuit het evolutiestandpunt  en ik
denk
dat het een
deel is van de vraag die Stephen eerder stelde,
zoals kunnen we meerdere
trajecten nemen, of het nu van boven naar beneden
is om tot dezelfde
conclusie te komen of hetzelfde als eindpunt
um
en dit is zoiets als in evolutie,
er is zoiets als convergente evolutie  waar
je weet dat totaal verschillende
genetisch niet-verwante soorten
dezelfde eigenschap zullen krijgen of of een
zeer vergelijkbaar uiterlijk zullen ontwikkelen waardoor
mensen denken zoals je weet voordat we
dna-relaties hadden alsof
we soorten op één hoop hadden gegooid vanwege
hun vergelijkbare uiterlijk die
eigenlijk
helemaal niet verwant waren  zoals of heel
ver op de fylogenetische schaal
um zo zo alsof het een aanpassing is waar we naar
convergeren  dezelfde functie of we
convergeren naar hetzelfde argument of
dezelfde plaats in een soort ruimte
en dit is iets waar ik
veel over nadenk
en ik ga het kwantumperspectief
leuk vinden, zoals kunnen we weten dat
alles van je weet  punt a naar punt
alsof je een ander traject aflegt,
maar alsof alles in de tijd
omkeerbaar is, dan is dat niet echt
mogelijk omdat we niet naar hetzelfde punt kunnen convergeren
alsof we een specifiek pad moeten volgen
als de omkeerbaarheid van de tijd waar is
sorry moest net zo gooien  dat daarin
interessant is,
nee, laten we terugkeren naar enkele van onze
eerdere
kaders, maar
leuke dingen, ik denk dat
we wisten dat we het merkteken op de deken wilden dekken,
we hebben
enkele van de
draden onderzocht die
het
realistische of zelfs
verdere standpunt rechtvaardigen,
hoewel we nog steeds  heb veel vragen
van de laatste 20 minuten of wat dan ook
over wat iemand leidt en wat
de implicaties zijn voor verschillende
standpunten oorzaken en gevolgen van
verschillende st  waarom is dat
in het algemeen van belang het bestuderen van kristallografie waarom
is dat van belang voor de sociale omgeving
zoals besluitvorming en bestuur of
organisatie
dat was een algemene rechtvaardiging
voor het vermogen van ontvoering
om verenigbaar te zijn met actieve gevolgtrekking
en een soort waarschijnlijk waardevolle
relatie te vormen in beide richtingen omdat
actieve  gevolgtrekking wint deze cognitieve
kenmerken
die werden beschreven voordat basisgrafieken
werden uitgevonden
analoog aan de suggestie van blauw
dat er classificaties waren waarvan
sommige echt inzichtelijk waren, andere waren
valse klonters of klonters of wat dan ook
voordat er een manier was om het
anders te bekijken,
dat is wat  van wat
een realistische interpretatie is, maar nogmaals,
we zijn nog steeds niet volledig gesloten over wat het
betekent om realist te zijn of waarom het ertoe doet,
maar laten we nu naar het concept van de deken
inactiviteit gaan
en op dezelfde manier hun
hoek op de deken afbreken
en misschien begrijpen wat  hen leidt en
wat hun voorgestelde implicaties zijn?  zijn
in dat opzicht
wat voor soort persoon ze denken
te zijn door deze
cognitieve sociale positie in te nemen
die kan worden gevraagd van zowel kranten als
alle uh spraakactie
en dan eh
waar is het vlees
,
wat is dan het
wat is de tussen
daar zo  iedereen kan ervoor gaan
wat is eh
iets om een actie dekens in te brengen en of
hoe alles
bij elkaar wordt gebracht in hi
polyta en vanessa 21. ja de
aan ja neem je tijd dus e
n van de dingen die ik erg leuk vind
an dit papier is weer  het is
de tijd die het kost
en dat ze dat sterk benadrukken
als onderdeel van deze co-constructie
die
mensen in staat stelt enig idee te krijgen van
wat
het betekent om in een nu
sociale situatie te zijn waar ze het
over hebben
en ik weet niet zeker waar  het staat in de
krant, maar ze praten over het feit
dat mensen die
nieuw zijn in een culturele omgeving
het
enige
tijd van hen nodig heeft om
de niet-linguïstische
non-verbale
niet-uitgedrukte taal op te pikken  in  formatie die
binnen dat sociale domein wordt doorgegeven en die
ze niet oppikken
, dus
wat maakt dat mogelijk en dat is
dan wanneer ze een
beetje tijd besteden aan het
praten over
waarom dat alleen dan als een co-constructie kan worden beschouwd,
de  hoe meer je doet
binnen die conditie hoe meer je
oppikt je kunt niet gewoon
toekijken je kunt
eigenlijk niet de overgang van
toeschouwer naar
daadwerkelijke doener en dat is dus een zware
die een zware last
is om op
het statistische
landschap te leggen
omdat  je gaat daar niet zitten en
gaat oké, dus wat is de kans dat
deze persoon die ik niet echt kan
begrijpen omdat ik niet eens
lengte wil, niet eens weet wat ze
zeggen omdat ze een
ander spreken  taal
wat is het probleem alsof je daar niet
zit en
dat soort berekeningen doet of
misschien wel,
maar je bent je er gewoon niet van bewust en
je besteedt niet veel tijd
aan je rekenmachine
om erachter te komen  uit wat de  wat de
distributie is
terwijl je probeert te
co-construeren
of te coördineren
je actieve betrokkenheid bij dit nieuwe
ding waar je nu
deel van probeert uit te maken,
dus
dat is een van de argumenten die ik
erg leuk vind aan
hun paper, ze eigenlijk
om dit te laten werken, moeten we eerst
beseffen dat er een tijdelijke
toewijding is
om in de toekomst iets te laten gebeuren dat
zou kunnen als je
die tijdelijke toewijding niet hebt als je
uitcheckt voordat je zelfs maar hebt ingecheckt
verandert er niets  er gebeurt niets
zo
vanuit een algemeen oogpunt dat
dat in wezen teruggaat naar de
discrepantievraag is het is het is een
harde grens, goed je kunt het op
die manier waarnemen er is nu deze beperking
omdat ik hun taal niet spreek
of
je kunt kijken naar  het zoals nu wat is dit
wat is deze evoluerende discrepantie en
hoe verandert het hoe verschuift het hoe
wijkt het af en komt het dan weer overeen
uiteindelijk oscillerend naar een soort
overeenkomst
dat is het instrumentale stuk,
ik zeg alleen dat de meeste mensen daar niet
zitten om dat uit te rekenen
terwijl het gebeurt, ze proberen eigenlijk gewoon
uit te zoeken wat olay betekent dat
blauw iets wil brengen op
een actiedeken
instrumentalisme en  dan kunnen we um
daarna kijken naar wat de inactieve
schrijvers zeggen
ik denk dat het is gezegd in het
inactivistische en instrumentalistische
algemene perspectief ik weet niet dat dat
altijd de klassieke manier is
waarop ik erover denk, maar laten we het even hebben
kijk wat de auteurs
zeggen oke
laten we in de eerste helft zien hoe ze
deze vraag hebben opgezet en dan
zullen we eindigen met een splitsing in de weg die
we goed kunnen
bespreken, zodat ze beginnen met een
gelijkaardige definiërende
deken die we zouden kunnen kijken naar de  woord
overlapt in de toekomst maar het is een
schaalvrij hulpmiddel weet niet of schaalvrij werd
gezegd in de andere situatie
het is geïntroduceerd als een statistisch hulpmiddel
waarmee we kunnen interpreteren
en dan zien we opnieuw toestaan voor inte
rpre
zodat
de taal al bepaalde flexibiliteiten heeft overgebracht
als men een liefdadige
maar beperkte lezing wil nemen,
dus dit is niet de enige manier om te lezen, maar
alleen in termen van hoe
onder de oppervlakte een argument wordt ingekaderd
als in
als in aanvulling op
de directe  retoriek
um
onmiddellijk overgaand naar de relatie
met de fysieke grens
in het ontvoeringsgeval zagen we de
nadruk op
de realiteit van de sluiting van de actie
en beïnvloede lus,
maar er was geen rechtvaardiging van een
fysieke grens en dus denk ik dat
het interessant is de  eerdere discussie
met als hoe helpt het multi-agent of
soortgelijke agent-gebaseerde modelperspectief
als een wetenschappelijk
hulpmiddel ons om
wazige systemen te modelleren als zwermen die een
bepaalde resolutie of dichtheid verwijderd zijn en
dan rechtstreeks naar
de frisse variant
van de markov-deken te gaan
waar er  zijn al actieve en
sensorische toestanden in plaats van
het eerst te introduceren in het algemene geval, zoals dat
het gaat om statistische isolatiesets
die ca  n dan onder
misschien sommige situaties worden
gepartitioneerd zoals een inkomend
vertegenwoordigend zin en dan een uitgaand
vertegenwoordigend actieaspect
en dat zijn dus de algemene toestanden
zin en actie s en a hier en dan b
in hun figuur is één de doos rond s
en a
en  dan uh de eta en de mu ze zijn
als een soort van flips van elkaar ik
denk niet dat dat de enige reden is waarom
het die letters zijn en ze
hoeven niet die letters te zijn geen van hen
hoeft echt te zijn  die letters, maar
dit is de verbondenheidsstructuur of
schaarste
van wat
beide auteurs goed
beschrijven, dan is hier de vork
het is mogelijk om actieve
gevolgtrekking op twee manieren te begrijpen
Ik denk dat we vandaag allemaal een paar manieren hadden
um een realistisch beeld dat d
eigenschappen  van het model moet
worden verwacht dat het bestaat als een ontologische
eigenschap
in dot dot ontologisch zijn zoals
niet
in het gebruik van de actieve inferentie-
ontologie die
belangrijk genoeg anders is,
maar eerder het beschrijven van
de phi  losofische ontologische of echte
basis daarom wordt het geassocieerd met
realisme
dan is de tweede manier de niet-realistische
opvatting dat het model gewoon een
instrumenteel hulpmiddel is,
dus
we zijn op de splitsing
van deze twee
richtingen
wat is de zet decaan
mijn mijn gevoel van de  film is dat
dat dus geen geheel vormt en ik
zeg niet dat in de
tautologische zin ik zeg dat als we
actief conclusies trekken in plaats van te kijken
naar een onderwerp met de titel actieve
inferentie,
willen we dat dan niet
opnemen  het geheel de complexiteit
of
omwille van het kunnen
begrijpen van
een actie
is actieve gevolgtrekking soort van
het is
mijn vraag zou zijn hoe actieve
gevolgtrekking daadwerkelijk wordt gebruikt in elk van
deze artikelen
is het is het is het
is het
het argument dat we niet door andere geesten de
voltooiing van de theorie rond de theorie willen krijgen
of zit het
bovenop dat soort kers op
de
manier waarop het ervoor kan zorgen dat we niet
te
ver afdwalen  het spoor  s mijn argument is dat
het beide is
als we actief
blauw afleiden enige gedachten
ik weet niet hoe actief in het frans
wordt gebruikt in elke krant ik ging
gewoon zoals het lijkt op wat is
het bericht naar huis rijden ik bedoel  misschien is
dat iets dat we ook voor
de punt kunnen achterlaten
eh
waar is de grafische samenvatting
goed voor al deze strings uh nou
het is moeilijk om dingen uit het ontvoeringspapier te vissen
vanwege het gebrek aan
cijfers eh ik moest het leuk vinden ga zoeken  mijn eigen
cijfers want voor het mooie plaatje
oke laten we een laag dieper kijken naar de
um
de drie
manieren waarop ze suggereren dat je een
niet-realist kunt zijn over Markov-dekens,
het zou een heel andere
kruisingskaart zijn met waar is
niet-realistische anti-  realist
pro-instrumentalist
we zouden gewoon politieke kompassen over
de hele kaart kunnen
doen en
er zouden zelfs
vragen van het tweede niveau zijn over hoe dingen worden gedefinieerd
in welke perioden en gewoon het is
allemaal goed
en dus proberen we
deze opnieuw te volgen,
ik vind decaan leuk  de manier waarop je
het terug hebt gebracht zoals navigeren in
deze continue ruimte tussen twee
varens
tussen twee polen
um
op zijn minst
en
dan blijft dat in een soort dynamische
navigatieomgeving en dan als je de mot bent, dan is dat
uh als je kunt  ga niet te dicht bij de
lantaarn, geen van beide lantaarns
als je er een raakt, dan sterf je,
dus je vlucht stopt daar,
zodat ik denk dat het
een zeer
zinvolle uh interpretatieve laag vormt,
want zoals
gezegd helpen de cijfers bij de
interpretatie
en kortere lijsten helpen alsof er
drie redenen zijn  waarom ik hier tegen ben
ze zijn een twee en drie dat zijn
belangrijke structuren
maar er is ook een reden dat mensen
niet communiceren via contouren
buiten bepaalde situaties
oke
zo raak maar wat zijn de drie manieren
waarop ze suggereren dat men kan  wees een
niet-realist over markov-dekens
een
betekenis minder
semantische hulpmiddelen
dit wordt denk ik heel
interessant
ze hebben geen semantische waarde
interpretatieve
waarde
lingui  stic of anderszins
anders dan geconstrueerd door
ze te gebruiken om gedrag te begrijpen of te voorspellen
in de situatie waarin de wetenschapper
het stopteken bestudeert
, zouden ze kunnen zeggen dat de statistische voorsprong
voor mij bij de mijne
instrumenteel wordt gebruikt
en er een geldig standpunt zou zijn,
maar vooral  wanneer we deze
semiotische
kijk nemen die erg lijkt op semantiek
en ze hebben hetzelfde zaad, maar de
semiosis
met het stopteken en het daadwerkelijke
stoppen en de sociale en actie van
stoppen en de ontwikkeling van de
agent die ertoe leidde dat ze dat
geloof daarin hadden  context
die het niet alleen opstelt in termen
van
louter propositielogica
waarnaar we verwezen
in de punt nul en
veel van de peerson de commons.org-
artikelen leggen het veel dieper uit, maar
ontvoering is niet alleen
een statische
set regels alleen
de genererende selectiecyclus omvat
op zijn minst
gestructureerde nieuwigheid die voortkomt
uit intern extern en alles
daartussenin
en een continu type attentie  n
distributie
en strategie op aandacht enzovoort, dus
het is een veel rijkere setting
dan potentieel
semantisch, wat in bepaalde situaties symbolisch kan betekenen,
dat wil zeggen het
soort symbolische logica dat wordt uitgevoerd door
als een turingmachine die nog steeds uitgebreid kan zijn,
dus zelfs een genereus
interpretatie is nog steeds erg
plausibel,
maar er is iets anders aan
semiose
en het biosemiotische dat werd genoemd
in het andere artikel
dat niet hetzelfde is als de
modellering van de onderzoekers
en dat ook
goed werd onderzocht door gele burnberg in het artikel uit
2016 het anticiperende brein  is geen
wetenschapper
die een wetenschappelijke analysemodaliteit contrasteerde
met
het cognitieve systeem als kenner en
die cognitieve wetenschap op een bepaalde
manier onderscheidt van die door ecologische
psychologie decaan
ja ik wilde daar gewoon op
inhaken ik denk dat het om
dit te laten gebeuren denk ik  in theorie is het
gemakkelijk om te zeggen dat
we niet wachten op onze priors
ik gewoon niet ik blijf objecti  Ik heb
dit allemaal meegemaakt, maar ik denk niet
dat de meesten van ons, zelfs als we die
echt, echt strikte wetenschappelijke
houding aannemen, zich bewust zijn van de prioriteiten
en de gewichten die we
zelfs onbewust hebben toegepast,
dus
nogmaals,
ik denk dat
je kunt zeggen dat
er is  nee er is geen waarde aan toe te voegen
ik ben gewoon ik ben gewoon ik heb mezelf
ervan verwijderd en ik ben er slechts een passieve waarnemer
van
maar ik weet niet zeker hoe lang we
passief blijven voordat we gewichten gaan toepassen
en  waarden voor wat het is dat
we
analyseren, vooral in een situatie,
vooral in situationele analyses
die persoonlijk zijn en de gevolgen
op ons terugvallen en nu als je gewoon
naar iets kijkt en er geen
gevolgen zijn voor jou als waarnemer
misschien is dat gemakkelijker om te doen, maar als je
op een plek komt
waar de wetenschapper deel uitmaakt van het
experiment,
laat me dan zien hoe
die schakelaar wordt uitgeschakeld en je
geen gewicht hecht aan iets
heel
krachtigs en waars en op veel manieren
impliciet en  e
Het soort berichten dat ik soms
in de informatieomgeving zie,
gaat over mensen ertoe brengen hun
verleden bij te werken om te geloven dat ze deel uitmaken
van een groter probleem
, namelijk een absoluut geldige
communicatie en perspectief
en het hoe
van het pad
en de homeostase en  het
systeem met meerdere niveaus
en het kritieke pad dat het moet
volgen,
inclusief reflexiviteit en verhaal en
anticipatie
en dit bottom-up top-down
aspect is dat sociale passiviteit
zoals mensen kunnen beweren dat er
verschillende sociale structuren zijn in verschillende
omgevingen
en dat doet het niet'  Het hoeft geen top-bottom te zijn,
het hoeft geen specifieke
metafoor of psycho-psychoanalytische
lens te zijn
,
maar de enige kortere weg
om
al die complexiteit
in
een datapunt samen te vatten,
deze ene truc
is
om het als een experiment te benaderen
want dat is wat het experiment is,
in zekere zin gaat het om het vinden van een spruitstuk
waar het is alsof deze buis deze
streng dna heeft en dit  set van dingen
en dan kan de
verf op de muur en al deze andere
factoren van de ware
context worden
geïsoleerd van dat is een beetje zoals de
gedeeltelijke informatie-inkapseling
of gewoon een ander type systeem
en dan zien we mogelijk zoals met
kwantum
ja
sommige  aanhoudende anomalieën
die suggereerden dat dingen niet altijd waren zoals
ze leken,
maar de echte case study is niet de
kwantummechanica, maar het is de bayesiaanse
mechanica
met de psychologische studie
en de neuroimaging-studie en de
gedragsstudie
door
allerlei soorten
mensen
in alle sociale en actiesettings
en
[muziek]
die echt wijst op enkele van
de diepere implicaties van
interactionisme
formele modellering van sociale en cognitieve
systemen
men
zou uit dat echte leven kunnen stappen
en een ander binnengaan
en zichzelf situeren vanuit het perspectief van een
derde persoon
en
hierop terugkijken  enkel pad vlak
en zie dat als een experimentator
en dat wordt in veel opzichten geassocieerd met
meta  cognitie
echter
kan die waarnemer
realisme versus instrumentalisme claimen van
waaruit spreken mensen in
termen van die visie
ik weet niet ik breng gewoon dat soort dingen ter sprake
zoals ben jij
waar
ben jij en dat heeft echt betrekking op het
zelfconcept van  blauw opgevoed en houdt van
het soort gesitueerdheid met het
zelfconcept en vervolgens realistische instrumentalist,
maar laten we verder gaan met deze punten
tweede reden waarom men een
niet-realist zou kunnen zijn over opmaakdekens,
men zou ze alleen als waardevolle
ficties kunnen zien
ja oke die abstractie mogelijk maken  bepaalde
kenmerken van een fenomeen,
maar een waardevolle fictie
die je zou kunnen vragen zijn alle gegenereerde
interpretaties
fictie is waardevol of niet
of zo is
zeggen dat het een fictie is en zeggen dat
alles een fictie
is dat eh
op welke manieren is dat instrumenteel of op
welke manieren is dat  realist
die een echte claim maakt dat dat het
spul is dat alle dingen zijn,
hoewel het niet van het spul is dat
mogelijk iemand over atomen is geleerd
in een bepaald klaslokaal,
dus de aanhoudende divergentie kan
sommigen ertoe brengen te denken dat een van die
wetenschappelijk gefundeerd is en een andere
metafysisch gefundeerd is
en of openstaat voor voorkeur geloof
of andere
uh
voorkeuren en zorgen die discussie aangaan
en dan eh oke de derde is dat
je zou kunnen  wees een non-realist over Markov-
dekens,
want
alleen omdat het succes van het gebruik
van de markup-deken
de acceptatie van de
epistemische waarde van het model rechtvaardigt
zonder noodzakelijkerwijs ontologische
claims te maken,
met andere woorden
alleen omdat het epicykelmodel goed
past, niet  betekent dat het echt een epicykel is,
alleen omdat het cirkelvormige baanmodel
goed past
hoe goed 99
totdat iemand langskomt en 99,9 gaat
met een totaal andere modelstructuur,
dus het is net zoiets als zeggen
hoe zeker je zou kunnen zijn van een realistische
interpretatie van de structuur van  het
model
wanneer ze,
als onderdeel van iemands toewijding aan het
wetenschappelijke proces, de
deur uit zouden gaan  open
voor een toekomstig model met een hogere
verklarende voorspellende kracht ontwerp en
controle et cetera decaan
ja dat is en ik weet niet waar het is
in de
we hadden het eigenlijk omdat
ik vanmorgen naar de dia's van de 47-0 keek
en er is  a er is een deel
dat wordt benadrukt in de andere krant
de gesprekken waar pierce zegt laat de
deur open dat is waar ontvoering over gaat
het is gewoon de deur is een pot je hebt
geen zekerheid maar je hebt genoeg
van je hebt genoeg
informatie
om
een  hypothese geen verklaring voor de beste
of niet
iets eerder de beste verklaring
maar je kunt nu iets
hebben om van af te gaan om van
te profiteren en dat is omdat
de deur open was gelaten dus je kunt
er weer vanaf komen
je kunt komen  bij deze conclusie dat de
derde het succes van de Markov-
deken door de instrumentalistische lens is,
maar er zijn mensen aan de realistische kant
die hetzelfde zeggen, hoe
opener,
hoe waarschijnlijker het is dat je'  Ik
kom eerder op
de details,
hier is een leuke
analogie van een mier om het
terug te brengen naar het eerdere verzoek van uh steven.
bepaalde
ontsnappingsevacuatiesituaties zoals het verlaten van een
kamer waar alarmferomoon is
verspreid
dat wanneer er een vernauwing is in
de uitgangen, dus de morfologie van het nest
dat ze hebben gebouwd
wanneer er een vernauwing is
die situatie in autoverkeersopstoppingen en
in
mensenmassa's situaties kan  zeer dodelijk zijn
en dat het kan worden geassocieerd met
een
situatie van verliefdheid of een vloeistof tot vast
zoals vastgelopen en dan een breuk die
allerlei problemen kan hebben
in het midden van waar het gebeurt,
terwijl ze bij de mieren hun
individuele bewegingen vertragen
dus het was niet zo'n ordelijke rij
iedereen in de rij gaan staan en nu gaan we wa
hten op nummer zo en zo om gebeld te worden dit w
s als hun a
twoord  se in de situatie
met de biosemiotica
en de niche-constructie van ontsnapping
rechts
was een langzamere en snellere reactie
, zodat ja hun morfologie als
nestgenoten hen helpt door poten te hebben
die wit zijn
, ze zijn fysiek
isolerend, dus het wil niet zeggen dat  dat
is het
enige dat een mens semantisch
in gedachten moet houden in een fysieke ontsnappingsomgeving,
maar actieve gevolgtrekking
laat ons teruggaan naar
die verschillende instellingen
en kijken naar de mieren
en hun uitzicht van binnenuit de
endosymbiose zoals de
feromoonperceptie de neurobiologie van de
nestgenoot en dan is er de exosymbiose
met de wetenschapper
en dan
zijn er
instrumenten in het spel
decaan
dus je denkt niet door
mierengeesten die ttam in plaats van ttym zouden zijn,
maar
er is een gevoel
dat er zelfs een bijenkorf aan het
werk is  hoewel je die verborgen geest niet noodzakelijkerwijs kunt
delen
, is er geen vermenging, er is
een autonomie
en er is een gevoel dat
als ik
een gelovige ben in de top-d  eigen versie die mogelijk
wordt gemaakt door een activisme
als ik daarin gelovig ben kan ik ook
begrijpen
met zonder door de geest van een realist na te denken
wat dat realistische
perspectief is,
dus
jij bent niet
we zijn we zijn niet ik zou ik zou  zeg
dat wat Thomas en Inez schreven
vanuit een logisch standpunt
heel logisch is,
maar dat diskwalificeert
me niet mijn mijn denken
en deze andere manier van denken
van naast elkaar bestaan
en hebbend ik denk niet dat ik weet het niet
als het antwoord naar Daniel kijkt of
niet, misschien zijn ze dat, ik bedoel misschien is er een
ander verhaal dat Daniel
met ons zal delen over wanneer de
mieren zich van hem bewust werden, maar ik zal
je een kort verhaal vertellen ik
voer eksters ik voer banen
en wat de corvids  realiseerde me dat ik het ben
omdat ze heel snel
gezichten herkennen
en wat ze doen is dat ze de gunst teruggeven die
ik krijg
kleine um
ik krijg botten van van
dode dingen die ze hebben gegeten ik krijg de
botten op hetzelfde  rock die ik plaats
de
de hond f  oeps want ze houden van
dit hondenvoer met vissmaak, ze
geven dingen terug en dragen
terug omdat ze willen dat ik
die cyclus voortzet, dus ik weet niet of mieren dat doen
, maar ik ken die andere soorten wel
of ze het zouden beschrijven als
wetende dat mijn geest
zeker mijn gedrag wil beïnvloeden
vanuit een strategisch standpunt
geweldig veel punten daar
dus dat staat
in contrast met een
raamwerk zoals pan psychism of zoals
de afwezigheid van psychism dus gewoon volledig
opzij zetten van veel van die vragen die
je beschreef als een pan-  opzettelijke
houding is
een pan-strategie
die zorgt voor complexe holobionts blues
microbioom
evenals de menselijke hond supply chain
kraai
setting
waardoor die kunnen
bestaan en worden gemodelleerd door soortgelijke beslu
tvorming controletheorie speltheorie enz. vanwe
e het pragmatisme van het spel
s het als  een doorgang
om al deze situaties te beschouwen
als iets om sommige spellen te spelen om
door sommige spellen te signaleren om op
deze manier te winnen of om de  is de uitkomst,
dus dat is best interessant,
dan
denk je aan
andere soorten, dat is een heel interessant
idee en het zou cool zijn om ervaringen te ontwerpen
, zoals door middel van games of kunst
die verschillende soorten
communicatie mogelijk maken
en dan
op het punt in de ontvoeringspaper
over  de economie van de wetenschap waarop we
kunnen terugkeren naar die bespreking van
het concept van Pearson
het is alsof je door de geest van recensenten denkt
en dus gewoon ook facetten ziet
of door de geest van mijn borst
denkt, het is geen totale emulatie
[Muziek]
maar nee, maar het is in staat om
interfaces te genereren  beleid
Er is zoveel
in een gedeeltelijke informatiesituatie
dat de entiteit moet genereren
en de generatieomvang betekent dat
er ook een sterk selectiemechanisme
moet zijn en dat zijn de cycli
van
temporele
abductieve logica
die ons
uit
de inductieve deductieve
statische conceptuele
dialectiek haalt
en dit brengt pragmatisme actie
ecologische psychologie enzovoort, dus het is
echt fascinerend om te zien wat
er vloeit
in die ruimte van
formele modellen van waarneming, cognitie
en actie
die duizenden jaren oud zijn en het
zal belangrijk zijn om zoveel
van deze verschillende draden te begrijpen
omdat ze niet allemaal kwantitatief zijn
en eh het ontvoerende papier en  de
sociale en actieve krant
demonstreert twee van de belangrijkste
gebieden waar dat het geval is decaan
ja, ga daar maar heel snel mee door,
dus het zou niet uitmaken of ik heb besloten
dat ik een situatieanalyse wilde doen
en die zou baseren op de  zeer reële
geschenkoefening
die gaande is of
ik interpreteer het tenminste als een
geschenkoefening dat zou een benadering zijn die
ik zou kunnen nemen de andere benadering die ik zou kunnen
nemen zou een zeer instrumentalistische zijn
in termen van
tokenuitwisseling, een van beide  dingen
zouden werken ze samen te voegen
zou misschien
nog meer additief kunnen zijn ik weet het niet zeker ik denk niet
dat het verwarrend zou zijn ik denk dat het
gewoon twee lenzen
op de
sa zou opleveren  mij
in hetzelfde
proces
kijkend naar
uh
hippolyta en vanessa's figuur twee en
drie
dus hier is
een perspectief op sociale
constructie
dat ze trekken vanuit
niet-inactivistische of niet-actieve gevolgtrekkingsperspectieven
het verschil met figuur 3 is de
sociale actie in figuur 2  onder het
actieve inferentieraamwerk
is de koppeling
en dus
lijkt er niet
eens iets te zijn
dat zou worden vastgelegd door deze grijze doos
in het midden van figuur 3.
dus
speel het veilig
neem een instrumentalistisch perspectief op deze
rijze doos
het is
een heel belangrijk
knooppunt en interpretatie
en geef dat dan door aan de
buizen door
aan de ontvoerende recensent
die ernaar kijkt en ja zegt en de
sociale actoren houden zich bezig met ontvoeringslogica
mijn achtergrond in pierce
suggereert dat ontvoering het
primaat van de generatieselectie en
de  tijddynamiek en de stroom van actie
met de omgeving
van pierce's
werkontvoering
kunnen worden geïnterpreteerd in een realistisch
kader,
zodat dit ca.  n instrumenteel worden vastgehouden met
deze
visie met dit oog
en men kan zich dan afvragen of de
ontvoering
die je modelleert met abductieve
logica
misschien zelfs een instrumentele houding kan aannemen,
maar is het instrumenteel voor de sociale
actor voor de endo semiosis in plaats van
van de axosemiose blauw
dus je nam me min of meer de woorden
uit de mond daar goed gedaan um dus zoals is
deze grijze doos deze
sociaal-culturele betekenissen en op modellen gebaseerde
redenering zoals kunnen die
worden ondergebracht
onder
exosemiose vraag je of kan het een  filter
zoals is exosemiosis
zoals
de toerekening van sociaal-culturele betekenissen
en modelgebaseerd redeneren is dat
exosamiosis
van de definities die ik heb gezien in
de gebruiken die ik heb gezien exo betekent
van buitenaf endo betekent inzicht in het
algemeen in wetenschappelijke woorden semiosis is
de  wat betekent bouwproces
dus
exosymbiose is een blik van buitenaf
bijvoorbeeld kijken naar dat stopbord
situatie ontvouwt zich kijken naar die
mierenferomoon situatie unf  oud,
terwijl de endosemiose het
interpretatieve semiotische proces is
waardoor iets een
interne
betekenis krijgt,
die dan kan worden gevraagd of het
op een symbolische of een cognitieve of een
aandachtsmanier is en al deze verschillende
aspecten, maar
ik hoop dat dat hoe dan ook een nauwkeurig
onderscheid is  jij bent eigenlijk jij bent jij bij
ik probeer dit eenvoudig te maken
voor mijn kleine brein
vraag je of een persoon een derde persoonsperspectief kan nemen,
dus ik probeer het gewoon te begrijpen
zoals endosemiose is heel duidelijk
voor mij
um
maar  zoals deze exo-semiose zoals wanneer
wanneer ik het leuk vind, zoek het goed op,
zo
um
endosemiose is als de
signaaloverdracht naar het interieur dat is
als endosymbiose zoals de
um
precies zoals de interpretatie van
tekens naar binnen, maar zoals deze
exosymbiose is zoals tussen
organismen  zoals de tekeninterpretatie
en signaaloverdracht tussen
organismen van dezelfde soort of van
verschillende soorten zoals bijvoorbeeld de
a  nt feromoon zoals dat is wat ik lees als
exosus, dus als je naar die figuur kijkt,
is dat niet exosis,
ik bedoel, het lijkt op een
modelweergave en wat was het
andere ding daar, dus ik ben op zoek naar
het
hier is een leuk uitzicht denk ik  op de exo dus
ja, ik denk dat we het hier eens zijn
endosomose is als de signalering in
het organisme of het zicht van binnenuit,
maar
dat daar is ook het hart van ook
de grens als een fysieke versus
grens als een functionele dus
er is een geheel
complexiteit met biosemiotiek, wat volgens
mij meestal de reden is waarom mensen praten over
de
biosemiotiek en gewoon de complexiteit herkennen in
plaats van te vroeg een standpunt in te nemen
over die verdeling, maar dan is
dit het exosomatische perspectief
dat berichten construeert aan vermeende
buitenaardse wezens,
dus als we kijken wie  zijn de auteurs
die de auteurs zijn van dat artikel
ze staan hier vermeld douglas een coach maar
a, laten we um goed
oen, dus gewoon dit als socio
ulturele betekenistoerekening en en  zoals in de
meme-paper die um daniel en ik
net uitbrachten en in
um
met rj en marijua um
deze semiotische representatie is
cultureel
vergelijkbaar
relatief ik bedoel alsof er geen
stopbord is zal geen stopbord zijn
om iemand leuk te vinden in like  de aboriginal
lijkt erg op inheemse primitieve um
zoals levensstijl,
dus
deze exo-exosymbiotische is als een
overdracht tussen
organismen van dezelfde soort, maar houdt
ook van dezelfde cultuur, zou ik zeggen,
want zoals hoe kun je het niet
leuk vinden
en zelfs ik niet'  ik weet niet of dat waar is in
feromonen alsof feromonen en
verschillende mierensoorten
verschillende dingen betekenen zoals hetzelfde
feromonen kan meer dan één betekenis hebben
is dat ook waar
of hetzelfde soort moleculaire
verbinding ik bedoel ik denk dat we waarschijnlijk
niet genoeg weten
ik denk dat ik denk dat ik begrijp wat je
nu vraagt,
is er een verondersteld
gevoel
dat er
een of andere vorm van
verstrengeling aanwezig moet zijn
om iets van dat alles logisch te maken
imp  leugens dat er iets heeft bestaan
sschien niet bestond in he
in het verre verleden het niet
ou bestaan in een andere context dus daarom
e sociaal-culturele betekenisse
zoals zoals ik denk aan dat als exo exo
imiosis jij bedoel
k
het spreekt voor zich dat
er gewoon verschillende
nabijheid is langs verschillende assen,
zoals mensen die dezelfde
taal spreken maar verschillende
woordenschat of
je weet dat
de situatie zoveel uitmaakt van
lichaamstaal dan
hoe
distaal of anders de cognitieve
structuur is
ten opzichte van wat
het wordt  moeilijker om te citeren, plaats jezelf
in hun schoenen
enzovoort
en ik heb het gevoel dat dat een grote
vraag is met de multi-schaal
systeemfenomenen of ze dissipatief zijn
of aanhoudend
diverse intelligenties
begrijpen in wat het water waarin we
zwemmen cognitief en taalkundig is,
omdat het water  we zwemmen in een deel
ervan zal het signaal zijn
voor iets anders
het zou het invloedssignaal kunnen zijn
zoals de b-matrix in acti  nf beïnvloeden van
causale relaties in de wereld
als onderdeel van het water waarin je zwemt,
kan ook zijn als aanpassingen
door stigmargie niche-modificatie
zoals je fysieke invloeden
die het water kunnen zijn waarin je zwemt in de
zin dat je ze niet opmerkt zoals veel
dingen die  kom je van en via ons zijn
we ons niet direct bewust van,
dus ze zijn als de verf op de muren
in dat pcr-
experiment met het versterken van het dna,
omdat het de delen zijn die, of we het nu
leuk vinden of
niet, worden gecondenseerd tot een stip
of  een pad
en dan wordt dat onze gelijkaardige
zin door lokale gedeeltelijke informatie te maken
alsof veel van het onzichtbare deel
we gewoon zouden kunnen negeren en we
cognitief doen waar we het over hadden, zoals
de uitlaathitte met Chris Fields en
kwantum alsof je
informatie moet verbranden om  let op
en daarom en je moet
opletten om met een echt complexe
niche
om te gaan, dus er zijn veel
spanningen
op dat
pad
en
uh vooral met deze dyade en ik weet het
zeker  veel ander gerelateerd werk, maar met
dit duo
en ik denk dat met de lens die
decaan je hielp het te benaderen met
eh,
het zet sommige van die
draden in een ander licht
en vooral voor degenen die
op deze semiotische manier
een of andere bayesiaanse verrassing hadden een
cognitieve staat  updaten
van een aantal verschillende dingen
dat is als een proof of concept
sociale passiviteit,
maar niet in een
gecorrodeerde of in een uitvoerende kunst,
hoewel wie zou kunnen zeggen dat het geen
uitvoerende kunst is, maar nog steeds een manier die
het realisme in het sociale brengt
door de formele en andere deuren
uh  decaan en dan blauw
ik denk dat ik beide
papieren als pilaren zou zien ik zie ze
om verschillende redenen echt stabiliserend
en ik zou liever op mijn beide
voeten staan
s stabiels onder beide hebbe
en proberen erop te staan  één of
beide voeten op
één cilinder staan, omdat ik vind dat ik
dat
alleen op basis van mijn vorm moeilijker vind,
maar
toen we probeerden dit nieuwe seizoen
van livestreams op te pakken,  en het samenbrengen van twee
papers die aanvoelden als een grensmoment
en ik denk dat een van de dingen die
we hopelijk hebben overgebracht, is dat
kijken naar twee dingen tegelijk van
nature ingewikkelder is,
niet noodzakelijk complex de complexiteit
bestaat in elk van de papers, maar
naar twee dingen tegelijk kijken is
ingewikkelder en is daarom meer
beladen met de fout
van de trial and error-
relatie ik zeg niet dat we
een heleboel fouten hebben gemaakt, maar ik denk dat
de eerste
de eerste regel van generatie is
je zult het niet
meteen begrijpen,
je zult opnieuw die
tijdelijke
toewijding moeten hebben om te kunnen komen
waar je ook denkt te gaan
en ik wist niet echt waar
dit heen zou gaan, behalve
ik  ik vraag me af wat er gebeurt als we
ons aandachtsregime niet beperken, ik
wist niet per se dat we het aan het verbreden waren
, maar ik wist wel dat we op een gegeven moment
de auteurs zouden kunnen krijgen en
ons zouden vragen
waarom we deze twee kiezen, ik niet  denk het he
om noodzakelijkerwijs deze twee papieren te zijn, is het
gewoon dat
beide papieren
een mooie symfonie creëren en creëren,
dus
het kan elke set papieren zijn,
er is een chocolatier
of een wijnkenner voor nodig om de
koppeling echt speciaal te maken,
maar er zijn andere
situaties waarin elke koppeling  kan
potentieel vruchtbaar en inzichtelijk zijn, zoals
ik daar soms aan denk in een
gemeenschapscontext zoals je altijd
tussen nul en één context gaat delen
en waar je ook bent in dat continuüm,
de delen waar je deelt zijn
geweldig en de delen waar je  zijn
verschillend kunnen we ook respecteren als groot
of de overlap tussen twee papieren wow
het woordgebruik was tegengesteld
of het was als tegengesteld op een andere
manier
oke
en dan met de houding dus toen
dacht ik aan
het soort soortgelijke
spellen waar mensen  op een
enkele paal staan
tropische prachtige locatie en pr
beren niet te vallen, dus ik dacht dat als je be
de voeten hebt zoals je zei op één posit
e smal
an b
ffe
ten van overwinning  d zijn aanvallen op je
niet-evenwichtige stabiele toestand,
vooral als het is zoals wie van
deze ene persoon een professor gaat worden,
gewoon als een voorbeeld,
dus waarom niet
weerstand bieden
en terugkeren naar een vaste modus,
want dat is een soort van de modus
die dat zoekt  we hoorden in
recent werk van Dalton en Maxwell dat
de vaste modus het zwaartepunt is
en dan een andere manier die je beschrijft
met een soort van een niet-nul
divergentie en de ruimte ertussen is zoals
in
basketbal de drievoudige dreigingshouding
omdat  je zou kunnen dribbelen of passen of voorbij
schieten alsof je voor de basket gaat
en uh ja dat is een andere houding
en het is ook in een veld van aflossingen,
dus het is niet alleen dat ze in een
andere positie staan, zoals de voeten hier
zijn niet veel breder dan de  voeten hier
maar dit is de onderzoekende stemming
zoals pierce zou hebben eh
misschien erop gezinspeeld
dat in een context
met een actie ecologische psychologie dat
alles in een context
met een instrument
en een spel
en zo  alles buiten het spel dat
het spel ondersteunde
al die niveaus
zijn in de drievoudige dreiging, maar hoe ben
ik hier gekomen
waarom ben ik op de groene
is een beperkte context
en
ja, het is nog steeds zeer bekwaam niemand
vraagt zich af hoeve
l energie wordt gegot
n  om dat ding te doen, dat is hard werken
en er is een enorme beloning voor het
goed doen
en er zijn er veel en dus ik ben het er
helemaal mee eens en was niet eens van
plan dat mensen hier veel voor hadden kunnen trainen
dit zou iemand kunnen zijn die dat niet
doet'  ik speel geen basketbal
en daarom moet het een beetje
dynamisch en situationeel zijn,
maar als je ze ziet als een soort van extreme
vormen van papierinterpretatie in een
uitgebreide
interpretatieve metafoor op papier,
zou je
verschillende manieren kunnen zien om
semiosis uit literatuur
of discours te ontvangen
en
wat dan?  is de rol van deelname
en feedback en dan die multi-agent
setting die we noemden
hoop dat dat niet te willekeurig is
eh in onze laatste oh ja blauw ga ervoor
uh zo o  ne zoals het koppelen van papieren die
ik graag had willen doen, is dit
ontvoerende redeneerpapier met
het Chris Fields-kwantumpapier, dat
uit de jaren 40.
zoals omdat ik er net
zo erg aan herinnerde toen ik de
krant aan het lezen was
en  net als leren over abductief
redeneren en hoe dat eruit ziet
en en hoe zoals wij je kennen in
abductief redeneren je hebt geen
volledige informatie het is als gedeeltelijk
waarneembaar en dus alsof je gewoon
je beste voorspelling maakt van als een gedeeltelijke
observatie en het maakte  ik denk aan
de overlappende kwantumreferentieframes
waar je het niet leuk vindt alsof je
geen volledige overlap kunt krijgen met het kwantumreferentieframe van iemand anders
alsof het
niet zo is dat zelfs met perfect leren
er nog steeds wat ruis
of wat overlap zal zijn  tussen de
kwantumreferentie of een
incongruentie tussen de
kwantumreferentieframes een gebied
dat niet overlapt, dus ik weet het niet
, ik heb gewoon die twee dingen
die  het is als een koppeling die ik
graag had willen
zien,
dat is wat echt interessant is,
zoals eerder vermeld, het kwantum
brak het glas
op de reflexiviteitsvraag
[Muziek]
in de wetenschapsfilosofie ik hoop dat dat
niet te
overdreven is om te zeggen en dat was het ook niet  het enige
stuk in het gebouw of de verzwakking
van het glas, maar de
eerder genoemde hardnekkige anomalie met
betrekking tot de experimentele context
breidde de reikwijdte van bepaalde vragen
in de wetenschap uit tot
buiten het
discours in bepaalde culturele kringen
gedurende de laatste ongeveer 500 jaar dat
Stephen zinspeelde op delen van
zo kwantum is  waar deze
ontvoerende temporele relationaliteit
het is daar als je het nu ziet het is geen
protoactief deeltje oh als het
elektron gewoon een kiezelsteen
was, zou dit niet gebeuren
of
als het elektron een kiezelsteen was die
groter was, zou dit niet gebeuren, maar
zou het niet gebeuren  gebeuren of zou het
niet gebeuren omdat we
het beter zouden kunnen meten
al die vragen over
punten en deeltjes en wa  ves
onder bayesiaanse mechanica
als een mechanica voor cognitieve deeltjes
de reflexiviteit kan nu binnenstromen, niet alleen
van de
elektronenschaal,
maar ik heb het gevoel dat er meerdere
contactdiensten zijn
met reflexiviteit
op het semiotische
narratieve
ecologische
de echte schalen
buiten het experiment
en ik denk dat dat is wat
spreekt deels over
de manier waarop we dit zijn binnengekomen. een
discussie ook,
dus in onze laatste
vijf of tien minuten
wat zouden we willen
hebben of opmerking 4.2 alleen voor de auteurs of
ze hier
in de tijd tussen luisteren of niet we kijken
Ik kijk ernaar uit om met iedereen te praten die
wil, of het nu voor punt 2 is of voor een ander
punt in de toekomst, er is altijd een punt
3 aanbieding, dus we hopen deze discussie voort te zetten
met degenen die hebben geschreven
en degenen die nog niet hebben geschreven,
want er is zoveel
te doen  bouw voort op deze vector, dus
jullie zijn allebei vrij om zo lang als
je wilt,
gewoon alle punten te noemen die je wilt
bespreken voor volgende week die
decaan heeft meegebracht  eerder zoals
waar is actieve gevolgtrekking is het
de basis is het alsof je er bovenop rust
is er een soort dualiteit daar ik
denk dat dat iets is dat ik een beetje zou
willen terugkijken op elk papier en
erachter komen zoals  waar ik waar ik
actieve inferentie wil plaatsen in die pilaar of op
die pilaar
of is het de pilaar ik weet het niet
ja kunnen we gaan met
onze actieve inferentie gekleurde markeerstift
en oke zeggen deze twee woorden ja of jij
ken deze clausule yep deze paragraaf
met dit artikel
of deze interactie van het papier
dit hulpmiddel ontwikkeld door het papier
waar zou men willen benadrukken
hoe ik de papierdecaan zag
omdat ik weet dat stephen het volledig
eens zou zijn met luke kan ik je gewoon vragen
om  achter waar tussen haakjes als
zijn gevolgtrekking,
want nogmaals, ik denk dat dat er
zoveel toe doet als we het hebben over abductieve
logica
en retroductie het andere is
dat
ik
ik hoop dat die blauwe er goed over
nadenkt
Wat als we andere papieren zouden trekken en ze
verstrikt zouden raken wat wat terugvechten ik
hoop dat dat een opening is
en ik zal dit zeggen
het vergt een ongelooflijke hoeveelheid
voorbereiding
om twee papieren bij elkaar te krijgen en
niet het juiste respect te doen voor de hoeveelheid
werk die de
auteurs die de grondleggers van dat werk
hebben
gedaan, wat de voorbereiding ook
is in termen van kwantificering voor een
enkele paper om het recht te doen,
het zijn vele veelvouden daarvan om twee papers te citeren
, maar ik denk dat
als we actief gaan worden
niet alleen  materiedeskundigen die
actief concluderen
dat die oefening zo moeilijk en
tijdrovend is als het is
, het letterlijk verandert het
spel, omdat we hier vandaag nogal wat over het spel hebben gepraat
, waarvan ik
ook niet dacht dat het zou komen,
maar  godzijdank deed het,
want het is niet oppositioneel het spel
kan zijn
iedereen stapt in de kano
en werkt samen om bij de
hawaiiaanse eilanden te komen die letterlijk
letterlijk het spel kunnen zijn
ja, het hoeft geen
competitie te zijn,
het is geen race, maar overleven we
gezien de beperkte hoeveelheid informatie
die we hier moeten verzamelen
even
belangrijk voor ons vermogen om door te gaan,
denk ik dat dat is wat een actieve
conclusie is  is
dat waar de verschuiving van een
materiedeskundige naar een deskundige op het gebied van voorspellingsmaterie
eigenlijk overgaat,
dus
ik wil mensen nogmaals bedanken
voor wat het voelt alsof je jezelf
daar op een echt riskante manier ophangt,
want het is riskant dat is wat het is
nogmaals bedankt er is zoveel  om te zeggen dat ik hoop dat
het een eer en een voorrecht is
om in epistemische ruimtes
te zijn en
je homeostatische variabelen
beveiligd te hebben, zodat er een verbazingwekkende
ruimte wordt geopend en
het tijdelijke aspect van ontvoering
zo geweldig klinkt om naar terug te keren
omdat ik denk dat een andere van  die
contactpunten communicatie
is de dynamiek wat waren de enige
formalismen in beide documenten in termen van
gelijke vergelijkingen en wiskundige symbolen
het waren drie representaties van
dyna  micische systemen
van hipolito en van ness
om een contactpunt te verbinden en te aarden van w
aruit ze ee
standpunt innamen en een bekwame uitvo
ring in de
wi
kundige symbolische weten
chappelijke iemand zegt dat dit artikel een filos
fisch artikel is ja, maar het heeft verge
ijkingen, dus dat z
l worden  iets
anders
eh en
toen dacht je dat het lezen van een krant
het spel zou veranderen,
maar het lezen van meerdere kranten verandert het
spel en het is in zekere zin waar, het is
meer
rood om in gedachten te houden,
want
in ieder geval onder sommige
normen en voorkeuren voor papieren
discussies
zoals persoonlijk  ik geef er de voorkeur aan
en voel me thuis wanneer mensen
niet uitgebreid spreken
vanuit wat een persoon dacht en het
endosomische perspectief van hen
of van een hele cultuur nemen
die mij onwaarschijnlijk lijkt,
maar
de exosus van zichzelf situeert
in relatie tot een niet-triviale
endosymbiose
en waar komen die twee
draden samen in de deken
die
in potentieel zijn meest elegante grove
korrel wordt
weergegeven  door de grijze doos hier
en waarom zouden we willen afbakenen
of zelfs maar vastpakken
misschien zijn de grijpers die we op dit
moment
hebben
als autotangen
en dit is iets heel anders
en of iets actiefs
dus
op dit of enig moment lijkt het
absoluut geldig
om naar de structuur van figuur twee
en drie te kijken
en zoveel standpunten
tegelijk in te nemen of in snelle
navigatie dus
wauw wat een leuke discussie
bedankt steven voor het meedoen met blue en
dean
en we zullen uitkijken naar een aantal
interessante tijden in de
punt 2 en daarna  dus
wees gerust